for some people League of Legends has
become a very lonely experience players
are complaining that Riot's anti
toxicity measures over the years have
turned the game into an isolated silent
experience others have said that
League's increasingly sweaty
competitiveness is to blame so let's
talk about the league of
[Music]
loneliness League of Legends has been
called a lot of things over its 14-year
history massive addictive inventive well
balanced poorly balanced toxic
inspirational frustrating and at times
even fun yeah but one adjective that's
begun to creep in more and more over the
years is lonely for a lot of players
league is starting to feel lonely now
the first Theory as to why this is is
Riot's anti toxicity campaign a 2019
study by the Anti-Defamation League into
hate harass harassment and positive
social experiences in online games found
that 36% of league players experience
frequent harassment 27% of players
surveyed said they eventually ended up
quitting or avoiding the game due to
harassment and found that the game
ranked 12 out of 15 games studied for
positive social experiences toxicity is
something that Riot have been battling
in League of Legends since pretty much
day one and they've introduced a lot of
measures to combat it over the years 10
years ago Ryan introduced temporary chat
restrictions for toxic players limiting
their in-game messages for a number of
games four years ago league players
became able to permanently mute their
teammates and enemies in all games
forever this time last year Riot
introduced disruptive speech detection
that automatically mutes toxic teammates
in February of this year they introduced
the ability for players to mute
themselves and last month Riot removed
the ability for players to Ping their
allies they said a significant segment
of players players ping their teammates
death timers and the like for
non-constructive reasons and that they
think the game as a whole would be
better without this now Riot have been
eager to share the results of these and
other behavioral system changes most
recently in May where they said they'd
seen a positive trend in player Behavior
thanks in part to features such as
automatic muting I only mentioned a few
of Riot's measures there but I don't
think anyone can dispute they have been
making a real effort to combat toxicity
and I think anecdotally there has been
some improvement over the years but for
some players any reduction in toxicity
has kind of come at a price they argue
that League of Legends social experience
has become collateral damage in the
fight against toxicity and turn the game
into an isolated solitary experience in
any given game you have some players
that are chat restricted and are unable
to talk some players that are able to
talk but not willing and some players
that are able and willing to talk but
won't because they've deafened every
other player and the remaining players
without any communication restrictions
self-imposed or otherwise find that
they're just talking into the void their
words and pings not being replied to
maybe not even being seen the kind of
absurdity of this situation has not been
lost on the community many feel like the
ability to communicate is being Stripped
Away at an almost comical level but it's
not just the behavioral system that is
being blamed for the league of
loneliness others are blaming it on the
try hard sweaty nature of the game too
new players are immediate exposed to a
world of Smurfs who expect them to know
the game inside out all the Champions
their abilities their interactions with
each other items build pass early game
mid game late game strategy and whatever
the meta of the month is it's a lot and
if new low rank or casual players don't
keep up they're either going to get
flamed or soft inted or end up in that
silent bubble we've talked about now
some have blamed this hyper competitive
culture on Riot's push for the game to
become a sport in its own right that
this mentality has filtered throughout
the player base leaving it a better
place to try hard than to socialize and
honestly this might be a trade-off that
Riot are fully aware of some have
pointed out that the very complexity of
the game that has allowed League of
Legends to flourish as a spectator sport
has created an unfriendly atmosphere for
new or casual players who are looking
for something friendly and social the
argument here isn't that it's impossible
to have a sociable game that caters to
competitiveness and tries to Stamp Out
toxicity just that s approaches to
achieve those things may have
unintentionally led to a lonely
experience now one counter to this
argument is the existence of normal
games in League of Legends this is
supposed to be the place where you can
relax free from try Harding where you're
less likely to run into chat restricted
players or people who just full mute
themselves but even this week There's
Been complaints that Riot's new policy
of restricting toxic players from ranked
until they complete a certain amount of
normal games has turned normals into a
hellscape of Smurfs and Trolls but the
general wisdom over the years has been
hey if you want to chill out chat maybe
even make a friend or two play normals
if you want to sweat your own body
weight to gain LP that's what solo Q is
for the way I view it and the way we
view it is that solo Q is a it's a it's
a it is a
lonely solo esque experience it is only
about you it is there is no teamwork
there is no camaraderie there is none of
that that's exactly what it is it is
me versus everyone else on the ladder
even your teammates you will verse them
at some point so it's like there is
no there is no team I don't view it as a
it's not a team game at
all right in the grand schem of thing
now some of you might call that a
cynical view but I think it's a fair
point isn't solo qu supposed to be the
tryhard experience even if it's a lonely
one the riot o players are sociable
experience in ranked or have they
already carved that space out with
normals I think there is an argument to
be made made the loneliness that some
players are feeling is an unfortunate
but unavoidable byproduct of playing
competitive ranks it's a feeling that
may have gotten worse after riots ping
or chat changes or the game's growing
complexity but not because of them
necessarily is solo Q in League of
Legends the mode of choice for most
players of the game supposed to offer
people a sociable experience the
opposite of the loneliness we've been
talking about or is it supposed to offer
just a hyper competitive environment
where your not going to get verbally
abused or trolled because whether or not
you think they've been successful in
this that seems to be what Riot values
more highly when you look at the changes
they've made so do you think the league
of loneliness exists if so do you think
Riot has an obligation to change that
experience for the players affected or
do you think league players are looking
for sociability in all the wrong
places this is a gift from uh my
coworker Matt Massie who bought me this
while we were on the same work trip in
the UK this is a well-known pastry chain
I guess you could call it in in the UK
they basically keep half of like
Northern England running um On Any Given
morning um it's just funny wearing it
here in North America cuz I feel like
people might be like oh what's that is
that cool like European clothing brand
or something like no it's it's literally
a pastry
shop